there are some negative things that you
could say about Donald Trump what's
interesting is that the left almost
never says them and spent said they
spend a lot of time telling you how
Trump is a fascist who poses an imminent
and terrifying threat to our
constitutional order it sounds pretty
scary
is it true well consider the major
freedoms protected by our Bill of Rights
the document that makes America distinct
from all other countries freedom of
speech freedom of worship the right to
keep and bear arms due process under the
law now take a close look at today's
news
who exactly is threatening those
freedoms is it Donald Trump whatever is
false it is not Donald Trump it is the
left and they are doing it more
aggressively than they ever have before
as usual their critique of Trump is pure
projection if you want to know what the
left is actually doing listen to the way
they attack other people start with that
foundational freedom speech if they can
tell you what to say you are not free
there is nothing they can't make you do
that's where the founders put it first
it's the freedom that comes before all
others the left has spent decades trying
to weaken the First Amendment they've
done it in the sneakiest way possible by
creating phony hate speech exemptions
out of thin air so far the courts have
not accepted this idea that the idea
that you can limit speech simply because
someone else doesn't like it so the left
has a new plan now they've allied with
big corporations to make it impossible
for people who say the wrong things to
make a living in this country you may
have heard of a company called PayPal
it's an online payment platform the
biggest if you want to make money online
and many people do PayPal is essential
in a recent interview with The Wall
Street Journal the CEO of PayPal Dan
Schulman explained that diversity and
inclusion are his company's top values
but of course he doesn't mean it
he means the opposite like most on the
Left which Shulman actually wants is
utter conformity a world where only
approved opinions are allowed last year
PayPal banned Alex Jones from using its
platform for saying things they didn't
like they've also banned ant
Muslim activist Laura Loomer the
publication vide air and a number of
other people and organizations whose
speech they believe should be silenced
Schulman admitted that his company takes
guidance on who to ban from the Southern
Poverty Law Center that's an entirely
fraudulent organization that works as an
arm of the Democratic National Committee
according to showman quote the line
between free speech and hate nobody
teaches it to you in college nobody
defined it in the law well that's
ridiculous it is very much defined in
the law and has been for 50 years
in 1969 the Supreme Court conclusively
decided that hate speech does not exist
but it doesn't matter to Schulman or any
of his allies on the left to them the
First Amendment is merely a legal
obstacle it's something to subvert
rather than celebrate and PayPal is just
one small example of this across the
country the left is working to crash any
organization that stands in the way of
its power in New York State Governor
Andrew Cuomo is trying to shut down the
NRA why for the crime of disagreeing
with his agenda Cuomo is harassing
financial companies that do business
with the group and it's working the
media celebrate this just as they
celebrate the endless attacks on Fox
News their entire non profits whose only
purpose is to close the network you are
now watching
they are tireless and they are
well-funded if they someday succeed you
won't hear a word from the left about
censorship no they'll celebrate an
entire news media with one perspective
that's their goal total conformity which
is the same thing as obedience to
achieve that they're working to nullify
the Second Amendment as well
almost every Democrat now running for
president would like to disarm the
public and they say that out loud why do
you need assault weapons for hunting why
do you can't you have universal
background checks so much corruption so
much greed we can't actually pass
common-sense gun reform in this country
not because the American people aren't
behind it because they are but because
the NRA is more worried about gun sales
than they are about the well-being of
our kids we need to take on the NRA
expand background checks and the gun
show loophole
the United
States Congress needs to have the
backbone and courage to pass the NRA
smart gun safety laws common sense gun
reform the gun show loophole don't
believe a word those are just talking
points they don't mean any of it they
plan to take your guns away they have to
how else can they make the population
obey once you understand that their goal
is total control their policies begin to
make sense to a literal person for
example the green New Deal sounds like
it is something to do with the
environment it's green after all of
course if you really cared about the
environment the quality of air and water
you would push China to stop polluting
China is the world's biggest polluter by
far but the green New Deal doesn't even
mention China instead it's all about
controlling you the job you have the
house you live in the vehicle you drive
today those are choices that you get to
make under the green New Deal the
Democratic Party would make them for you
that's why so many of their candidates
have endorsed the green New Deal you'll
hear things like the green New Deal you
have your things like Medicare for all
your hair things like whether it's taxes
you'll hear things at what point you say
that's our North Star but we have to be
realists we there's no question we have
to be practical but being practical also
recognizes that climate change is an
existential threat to us as human beings
can we afford it of course we can afford
it two and a half three trillion dollars
a year for medicare for all by some
studies I know it's not about a cost
it's about an investment Medicare for
all another power grab a total federal
takeover of the health care sector that
means more power for them just the other
day congresswoman Acacio Cortes
speculated that may no longer be right
to have children kids today she
considers that a debatable question just
asking but in 20 years it may be settled
theology one morning you'll wake up and
Commissar Acacio Cortez will be
proposing control over who is allowed to
have children and when don't believe it
the same thing is happening with
reparations it moved fast 20 years ago
seizing people's possessions and giving
them away to atone for the sins of those
who
more than a century ago that was
considered a fringe position nobody said
that out loud who wanted to get elected
today Elizabeth Warren Kamla Harris will
be in Castro they have all said they're
for it at this pace we'll be knocking
down statues of Barack Obama someday
soon for the crime of opposing
reparations this all sounds a little
paranoid okay do this find a big-city
newspaper from just ten years ago read
the whole thing then compare it to this
morning's Washington Post how far has
the left moved in just a decade a long
way and the pace is quickening fascism
yep it's a threat and it's not coming
from the White House